on reçoit c'est qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs alors ce qui si c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
désignation à partir d'aujourd'hui des
maires de france qui ont été élus dès le
premier tour des municipales et parmi
eux un ministre celui de l'action et des
comptes publics gérald darmanin et lui
assure coin pour être maire ministre a
coordonné par l'exécutif alors qu'il
assurait le contraire avant la crise est
terre la règle non écrite veut qu'un
ministre ne puisse pas être à la tête
d'un petit but if locale
des mises en quarantaine à géométrie
variable en europe à partir du 8 juin ce
sera le cas pour les arrivants en france
en provenance du royaume uni une mesure
prise en réaction à la décision de
londres de l'application de son
territoire
l'espagne et l'italie espère la levée de
ces restrictions au début de la saison
touristique déjà mal en point à cause de
cette crise sanitaire
aux etats unis donald trump ordonne la
mise en berne des drapeaux en hommage
aux 96 mille victimes du courant navires
us depuis vendredi et jusqu'à dimanche
la bannière étoilée 9 plus sur les
édifices fédéraux américains nouvel
épicentre de la pandémie selon le msc
l'amérique latine et les caraïbes depuis
une semaine cette région enregistre le
plus de contamination avec en tête le
brésil
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi le début de
l'élection des maires qui ont gagné dès
le premier tour des municipales ça
commence donc aujourd'hui trente mille
communes sont concernées et parmi les
maires gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'éducation et des comptes publics qui
retrouve son siège qu'il avait occupé
entre 2014 et 2017
et il n'aura pas à choisir entre les
deux fonctions puisqu'il a été autorisé
à les cumuler pourtant avant la crise
sanitaire matignon avait bien averti
qu'il faudrait choisir entre la fonction
ministérielle et celle d'élu local
ce ne sera donc pas le cas finalement
gérald darmanin assure qu'il ne touchera
pas si indemnités de maire le temps de
ce cumul
il reste encore cinq mille mer à élire
et pour eux ce sera le 28 juin prochain
si la crise sanitaire le permet 2e tour
donc c'est ce qu'a annoncé hier le
premier ministre
un scrutin organisé avec la mise en
place de mesures de protection stricte
plus strictes en tout cas qu'au premier
tour le 15 mars dernier
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
les cérémonies religieuses autorisé à
reprendre à partir de ce samedi en
france le ministre de l'intérieur et les
responsables des cultes se sont accordés
sur les modalités sanitaires à respecter
concertation qui s'est imposé au
gouvernement après que le conseil d'état
lui a ordonné l lundi dernier de lever
dans un délai de 8 jours à
l'interdiction totale de réunions des
cultes figurant notamment dans le décret
de déconfinement du 11 mai cette
décision est le fruit du dialogue riche
et permanent que nous avons entretenu
avec les cultes depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire
nous avons travaillé et trouver une
solution pour permettre la reprise des
cérémonies religieuses tout en assurant
la protection sanitaire de chacun notre
volonté de protéger les français et de
limiter la circulation du virus n'a pas
changé nous avons confiance dans la
prudence et la vigilance exemplaire des
responsables des cultes
près d'un tiers des décès en france ont
été enregistrés à ce stade dans les
maisons de retraite et de nombreux
établissements sont aujourd'hui visé par
des plaintes pour leur gestion jugée
calamiteuse de la crise sanitaire des
avocats veulent faire un exemple et
regrouper ses actions en une seule au
niveau national il demande la mise en
place d'une juridiction unique
vous voyez les précisions de christophe
leguevaques il est justement l'un des
trois signataires l'un des trois avocats
signataires de ce texte dans l'espion du
dégoût on a des gens qui ont une
calculatrice à la place du coeur et
alors qu'il devrait mettre tout en
oeuvre pour que les personnes âgées dont
ils ont la charge soient bien traités
vont à voir avec l'esprit d'un comptable
des calculatrices à la main craquer les
économies de bouts de chandelles qu'on
peut faire pour justement réunir ses
économies et à y réaliser des dividendes
importants la faire
coville 19 mis en évidence que sur les
stocks notamment de masques
il y à des questions particulièrement
importante dans se poser il faut être
nombreux pour traquer les contradictions
montrer que tout cela c'est une
politique délibérée d'économies est
allah qui a abouti à ce résultat
aberrant que la france à 28000 décès à
ce jour à approximativement et plus de
la moitié sont dans les ehpad
c'est un signal fort ils montrent que le
traitement ou le soin été donnée par ces
établissements à nous et n'est donc pas
été à la hauteur
et alors que l'allemagne a plutôt bien
géré cette crise sanitaire depuis le 20
avril le pays a assoupli ses règles de
confinement vous rendre au moins
partiellement de nombreux secteurs
les manifestations pourtant se
multiplient contre des dispositions
jugées trop contraignantes par certains
et la chancelière angela merkel a dû
défendre publiquement ces mesures
écoutez là oui je peux comprendre ses
préoccupations et j'ai moi même dit au
bundestag allemand que ma déclaration
gouvernementale que ce virus est une
imposition à notre démocratie et c'est
pourquoi ce n'est pas facile avec les
restrictions sur les droits fondamentaux
par conséquent elle devrait être aussi
courte que possible mais elles sont
nécessaires et nous l'avons toujours
justifiée parce que nous nous sentons
responsables de la dignité des êtres
humains comme l'indiquent l'article 1 de
notre constitution ça y est c'est
pourquoi le moment est venu d'être unie
en europe est de montrer que nous
voulons rester forts ensemble le
gouvernement fédéral s'y est engagé dans
en ce qui concerne les programmes d'être
européen que sur l'organisation de notre
présidence au cours des six prochains
mois à partir du 1er juillet vers et
nous veillerons à ce que l'europe sorte
de cette crise en continuant à se battre
ensemble pour la paix et la prospérité
un berlin qui appelle l'europe à plus
d'unités alors que paris a entamé un
bras de fer le bras de fer de la
quarantaine
avec londres paris a décidé que les
voyageurs en provenance du royaume uni
seront soumis à une quarantaine
décisions prises dans réciprocité après
l annonce que tout voyageur étranger
arrivant sur le sol britannique sera
soumis à l'isolément à partir du 8 juin
prochain pour éviter évidemment la
propagation du virus
maintenant que nous avons passé le pic
de ce virus nous devons prendre des
mesures pour nous prémunir contre les
cas importés qui pourrait déclencher une
résurgence de cette maladie mortelle
forces in cheek winter pause 1-2 les cas
importés pourrait commencer à
représenter une menace plus importante
est accrue nous effectuerons des
vérifications ponctuelles d'ici la mi
juin pour nous assurer que les personnes
s'isole et les étrangers qui refusent de
se conformer aux règles pourraient se
voir refuser l'entrée dans le pays les
touristes étrangers pourront eux revenir
à partir du mois de juillet en espagne
déclaration faite cet après midi par le
premier ministre espagnol pedro sanchez
qui a annoncé également la reprise le 8
juin prochain du football professionnel
les cafés et les restaurants rouvriront
dès lundi à madrid et à barcelone malgré
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence
jusqu'au 6 juin l'espagne accueille
chaque année plus de 80 millions de
visiteurs
ainsi je vous annonce qu'à partir du
mois de juillet l'entrée du tourisme
étranger en espagne reprendra dans des
conditions sécurisées brûlures ainsi les
touristes étrangers peuvent dès
maintenant commencer à planifier leurs
vacances dans notre pays est ce voulu et
la belgique elle lance un nouveau projet
le projet dragons qui vise à mieux
diagnostiquer les patients et proposer
un meilleur pronostic clinique de quoi
s'agit-il
la réponse avec lucas mort bio était au
comble regarder et si l'homme et la
machine travailler main dans la main
c'est en tout cas le souhait de
l'entreprise en caux radio mix qui va
chapeauter le projet dragon ce programme
aura recours à l'intelligence
artificielle et au dip learning pour
aider les médecins à mieux diagnostiquer
la maladie et à choisir les traitements
en fonction
on va utiliser
et d'abord les images du patient décédé
scannage c'était et on va augmenter ses
données avec des données biologiques ou
des données de patients pour qu'il y ait
des modèles qui sont très forts a trouvé
des passions avec du coup vite à et a
essayé de pelé disent qu'elle est le
trajet pour ce patient continue à le
coup vite
cette pme a déjà mis au point un
programme en collaboration avec le chu
de liège pour déterminer si les patients
sont atteints du coc vite 19 grâce à une
radio en 3d des poumons d'un patient
l'outil est capable avec une précision
annoncé de 97% de déterminer si une
personne est atteinte du coroner virus
la procédure prend moins de dix minutes
alors qu'un test pcr pro trois jours
donc on a on les a contactés pour mettre
au point vraiment un outil de prise en
charge qui permettait de dire bah tiens
ce patient et la probabilité d'avoir un
kobe 19 ou pas trop et donc on a proposé
avec encore radio mix de base et une
analyse sur la présence d'une infection
par qu'ovide prouvé par les techniques
connues comme la pcr qui va permettre de
prouver le diagnostic et on a comparé
ces patients-là à plus de mille patients
qui ont d'autres maladies toutes
confondues sans faire la part des choses
entre les antécédents du patient
l'infection concomitants par une
bactérie la présence d'un cancer du
poumon
afin de pouvoir déterminer si oui ou non
on pouvait créer un outil performant
très spécifiques et donc très très
capable de pouvoir diagnostiquer
l'infection par co 26 nov
la pertinence du projet dragon a retenu
l'attention de l'union européenne dans
le cadre du mécanisme innovative
medicines initiative qui soutient la
recherche pharmaceutique
une subvention de 11,4 millions d'euros
vient d'être octroyée au projet 20
partenaires de belgique de chine
d'italie des pays bas de suisse et du
royaume uni seront réunis dans le cadre
du programme dragon par milieu une start
up belge med ces deux cette dernière
développe des applications pour aider
l'accompagnement des patients et des
médecins en proposant de l'information
individualisé par le biais de modèles
prédictifs donc en fonction de ses
besoins vécu effectivement on touche
la population de façon générale il va
recevoir de l'information déjà sur les
directives à jour à jour sur qu'est-ce
qui est recommandé on va lui proposer
des actions de prévention il va pouvoir
poser des questions directement à
l'application et avoir les réponses
qu'ils recherchent et on peut également
l'orienter vers les bonnes personnes
s'il ya des questions auxquelles nous on
ne peut pas répondre et ensuite
effectivement il ya tout un tas de
questionnaires qu'on va pouvoir utiliser
à des moments où le patient va avoir de
l'information sur son état de santé sur
ce qu'ils devraient faire qui vont
permettre donc de huy de lui donner les
bonnes directives en plus d'aider les
médecins pour le traitement des patients
atteints du coc vide 19
le projet dragon permettra aussi aux
patients d'utiliser eux mêmes certains
outils visant notamment à faciliter le
recours à la médecine préventive la fin
du ramadan c'est demain et contrairement
à la france en algérie les mosquées sont
toujours fermés l'algérie qui a continué
d'appliquer des mesures strictes pendant
cette fête religieuse 580 deux personnes
sont officiellement morte du coronavirus
dans ce pays
voyez ce reportage à alger des lamés
jahed avec les images de karim
benhamouda de maraudage production
habituellement le marché algérois est
bondée de monde
à quelques jours de l'aïd el fatah mais
le coc vie 19 est passée par là les
traditionnels préparatifs de la fête
sont moins visibles et c'est sans réelle
en train que l'on fait ses courses mais
que dieu me pardonne cette année là il
n'a pas de goût ce n'est pas comme avant
quand nous avions de longues soirées
pour nous préparer
maintenant il ne se passe rien
en fait depuis cette maladie rien ne va
plus en algérie
que voulez vous faire
c'est dieu qui nous oppose et en plus
c'est un problème mondial ça rien
coaching il faut être patient et surtout
gardons nos enfants à la maison et
armons nous passions il n'y a rien à
faire d'autre
nous aurions voulu que light se passe
autrement que nous nous rassemblions en
famille et pourquoi pas voyagé mais non
cette fête est traditionnellement un
moment où les familles rendent visite à
plusieurs de leurs proches
mais depuis le mois de mars les trains
les taxis et les transports en commun
sont à l'arrêt en algérie les écoles les
mosquées les cafés restaurants ou encore
les magasins de vêtements sont aussi
fermés une ambiance bien morose pour
certains épiciers à cause du courant
navires us laïque va être très
particulier cette année nous sommes
obligés de suivre les instructions de
l'êta et attendre que ça passe et que
cette maladie nous quitte en temps
normal cette période est caractérisée
par la ruée des algériens sur les
boutiques de prêt à porter pour se faire
beau à l'occasion de l'aïd
les consommateurs ont donc dû s'adapter
à la crise sanitaire et faire leurs
achats sur la toile
de la même manière que nous avons passé
le ramadan nous passerons l'aïd sans
rencontrer nos amis et nos familles et
comme les magasins se former nous
achetons sur internet se mettre sur son
31 et avoir une coupe impeccable
certains coiffeurs rendre service et
reçoivent les clients à leur domicile
c'est vrai qu'avec le confinement on ne
travaille plus notamment après
l'obligation de fermer boutique
mais en même temps nous les coiffeurs on
veut faciliter les choses pour nos
clients surtout en ces périodes de fin
de ramadan et de l'oeil les gens doivent
être bien coiffée mais il faut savoir
que nous n'avons pas les mêmes
conditions plus dans nos salons mais on
fait avec
avec une accélération du nombre de
contaminations aux coronavirus pendant
le ramadan les autorités ont pris
d'autres mesures pour l'aïd
les algériens ont l'interdiction de se
déplacer en voiture ce dimanche et ce
lundi le couvre feu lui a été durcie et
s'étend de 13 heures à 7 heures du matin
dans la capitale
les autorités locales ont explicitement
demandé aux habitants d'éviter les
regroupements familiaux et les contacts
sociaux nouvel épicentre de la pandémie
selon l' oms l'amérique du sud et les
caraïbes situation particulièrement
inquiétante notamment au brésil premier
pays le plus touché sur le continent sud
américain
la barre des 300 milles trois stèles et
des 330 mille cas a été franchi avec un
bilan de plus de 21 mille morts
et ce alors que le président aura hier
molson arrow fait l'objet d'une nouvelle
polémique
un juge de la cour suprême a rendu
publiques des images d'une réunion au
cours de laquelle chef de détail ce
ministre multiplie les dérapages verbaux
regardez ce qu'ils veulent c'est notre
sens notre liberté c'est la vérité ce
que ces types ont fait avec le virus 7
buts de ce gouverneur de sao paulo
cette carte de rio dé janeiro entre
autres c'est exactement cela
parce que si je fais une erreur si un
jour on trouve un lien entre moi et un
entrepreneur ou de l'argent sur un
compte en suisse
dans ce cas pas de problème il y aura
mise en accusation mais pas pour ses
absurdités ces conneries non
elle met le bazar dans ma famille j'ai
déjà essayé de changer officiellement ne
responsable de la sécurité à rio de
janeiro et je n'ai pas pu et on en parle
de cette nouvelle polémique avec auguste
al lunardi
journaliste indépendante bonsoir augusta
lunardi merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur rt france pourquoi le juge un juge
de la cour suprême rend-il public une
vidéo est ce que c'est un conte hareng
ou pour faire avancer une enquête
oui alors la justice au magazine elle a
décidé de justement de publier de rendre
publique cette vidéo
hier c'était une réunion ministérielle
censé être confidentiel mais cette vidéo
est hyper importante pour une enquête
parce qu'elle fait qu'elle enchaîne en
fait partie dans cette vidéo avec une
pièce clé dans l' enquête qui essaye
d'établir si j'allais molson araud a
tenté d'interférer illégalement dans des
enquêtes policières visant certains de
ses proches notamment ses fils et si les
accusations ont été formulées par l'ex
ministre de la justice sergio mon rôle
qui lui a démissionné juste après le
limogeage du chef de la police fédérale
mais cette vidéo aussi au monde
plusieurs dérapages du président walsall
un rôle comme par exemple une de ces
affirmations qui disait qu'il souhaite
armée la population pour éviter une
dictature l'instauration d'une dictature
au brésil mais ça montre aussi un des
dérapages de certains de ses ministres
comme celui de l'éducation qui s'attaque
à la cour suprême en dessin qui
voudraient mettre tous ces connards en
prison et il s'attaque aussi pardon et
le ministre de l'environnement admet
également sur cette réunion qui profite
du fait que les médias seront plus
focalisés sur le courant navires us pour
essayer de passer des réformes et
d'assouplir les règles notamment est
liée à la préservation de l'amazonie
alors effectivement ça montre un style
un peu particulier c'est un euphémisme
comment est-ce que c'est perçu par la
population
alors la population est très divisée il
ya quand même entières de la population
brésil et à qui continue de supporter un
jacques bolson arrow et qui même après
cette vidéo ces personnes pensent que
c'est très bien ce qu'il a fait et qu'il
faut tout de même armée la population
équine qui sont d'accord avec des rôles
swan haro sur le fait qu'il faudrait
dissoudre la cour suprême et le
parlement brésilien ce qui l'attend la
démocratie brésil et l'autre une autre
partie de la population est très
inquiète les scientifiques les
politologues brésilien alerte de plus en
plus une atteinte à la démocratie et
s'inquiète énormément car justement un
vol sonar ou un double discours est dit
que il s'attache énormément à la
démocratie mais il voudrait quand même
une intervention militaire si les choses
s'empirent au brésil donc la population
est divisée et certains s'inquiètent
énormément et d'autres fins sont
d'accord avec le président quand vous
disiez effectivement qu'il souhaite que
certains dé des brésiliens soir mais
c'est pour éviter les mesures de
confinement prise par certains
gouverneurs et pouvoir laisser cette
population aller dans la rue mais cesser
cette question là qu'il agace
particulièrement cette question du
confinement exactement baseball faglaro
il a déjà répété de nombreuses fois que
le confinement à était en train de tuer
l'économie brésilienne il a donné une
conférence de presse hier où il a
affirmé de nombreuses fois que sans une
économie les brésiliens vont mourir il a
utilisé des exemples absurdes comme en
afrique et il dit que l'économie est
plus importante que le confinement et
que ça pourrait qu'est que ça ferait
beaucoup plus de mal au porte-monnaie au
des brésiliens qui alors à la santé du
pays
il a dit aussi sur la déclaration d'hier
que oui il l'est
extrêmement désolés du nombre de morts
au brésil mais ne peut rien faire et que
surtout l'économie ne peut pas s'arrêter
que nous allons tous mourir un jour il a
déjà répété plusieurs fois ce type de ré
déclarations il ne semble pas avoir
changé de discours c'est un discours un
qui est un petit peu similaire à celui
de donald trump néanmoins cette vidéo
est ce qu'elle est recevable par la
justice quelle est la suite de cette
affaire
bon pour l'instant on n'a pas un port de
suite sans verra ce qui se passe sur la
cour suprême brésilienne
c'est difficile de savoir ce qui va se
passer dans les prochaines semaines mais
sait déjà où je pensais déjà c'est que
de plus en plus de voix s'élèvent pour
démarre dès le départ de bolt sonar ou
la destitution de molson araud que ce
soit chez l'opposition ont même parmi
certains gouverneurs qui était dans son
camp au début de la pandémie ou même des
pardons des députés de son propre parti
on ne sait pas encore sur tout tout est
très instable au brésil en ce moment et
on ne parle que de la pandémie donc on
verra dans les prochaines semaines ce
qui va se passer mais pour faire une
destitution de jeanne molson a rose
c'est plus compliqué que ça il faudrait
une votation au parlement qui est
complètement à l'arrêt en ce moment où
il ya un peu tôt encore pour le savoir
merci beaucoup on en reparlera avec vous
merci beaucoup à augusta lunardi d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france et
aux états unis justement donald trump
appelle lui à la reprise des cérémonies
religieuses le président américain qui a
exhorté les gouverneurs allait rouvrir
immédiatement ces lieux de culte la
mairie qui comptabilise près de 96 mille
décès elle n'est plus l'épicentre de la
pandémie
le président américain a ordonné la mise
en berne des drapeaux jusqu'à demain
dimanche en hommage aux victimes
justement de cette crise sanitaire les
états unis où les faillites se
multiplient c'est le cas notamment de
l'entreprise de location de voitures
hertz qui s'est déclaré en faillite la
nuit dernière une procédure qui ne
concerne que les états unis et le canada
ses filiales européennes sont pour le
moment épargné mais la deuxième
entreprise du secteur sur le sol
américain était déjà mal an
point avant la crise sanitaire mais elle
a vu sa dette exploser à 19 milliards de
dollars et le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi va aussi des records
outre-atlantique plus deux millions
quatre cent trente mille nouvelles
demandes d'allocations chômage la
semaine dernière
au total près de 39 millions de chômeurs
voyez l'analyse de christopher mais nous
il est avocat au barreau de paris et au
barreau de new york
alors la grande différence y compris les
systèmes économiques américains et
français et qu'il y à beaucoup plus de
souplesse concernant le marché du
travail aux etats unis
donc d'un côté il est beaucoup plus
facile de licencier les gens mais d'un
autre côté théoriquement blanche et de
travail est une soupe et il ya
impossibilité plus rapide pour certains
américains nous retrouver le travail
les américains regardent avant les notes
amour de la france avec notre système du
chômage dans ciel en se posant la
question pourquoi un tel régime n'existe
pas aux états unis alors un pas vers le
système et justin d'européens à commun
été fait par le président 30 en envoyant
les fameux chaque deux villes de 100
dollars à certains américains et
entonnant des traits et des subventions
à d'autres entreprises
donc c'est pas le système européen mais
on essaie on a compris aux états unis
qu'il est plus facile de matinée les
salariés en activité plutôt que de les
licencier et de reprendre une fois que
la reprise commence et c'est la fin de
ce journal à rester avec nous on se
retrouve dans 30 minutes
et
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la lie